[Music]
on this Monday night the crisis in
Canada's care homes residents in one
home abandoned left to die in their beds
I felt nauseous from hearing all this
the pleas for help and what needs to be
done to protect our elders a rapid
portable test that could be a
game-changer this would be a big help to
the testing system
how will it be scaled up and who will
get it new rules and protections for
temporary foreign workers key to our
food supply and the fans who were cut
out for this
baseball returns to Taiwan but with a
twist
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we begin another weekend during this
pandemic there are some promising signs
here in Canada it does appear physical
distancing is slowing the spread
Canadian hospitals have not been
overwhelmed with cases like northern
Italy and New York City but we also know
many Canadians are dying in their beds
in long-term care facilities where this
virus keeps spreading at an alarming
rate here are the official numbers at
least 780 people in Canada have now died
of kovat 19 nearly half of those are
linked to long-term care facilities and
that number is expected to rise often
those people are dying alone they've
been isolated in their rooms and
families are banned from visiting and
across this country families are
grieving at a distance tonight staff at
care homes are not well paid and often
work part-time and in multiple
facilities that increases the risk of
spreading the virus BC and Alberta have
banned that practice but other provinces
have not in Quebec changes are now being
made after 31 residents in one private
care home died in less than a month
Quebec Premier says every long-term care
home public and private will now be
inspected Mike Armstrong has our top
story tonight
Patricia DiBiase says her first reaction
to the revelations coming out of the
Haran seniors residence was nausea her
97 year old mother is inside and suffers
from dementia as funeral home trucks
continue to leave the residence DiBiase
and her husband say getting information
from anyone has been difficult and what
they do get they don't trust we've been
in our in our estimation lied to this
whole time through
the finger-pointing began as soon as the
body started being carried out of the
residence the local Health Authority
says it put the facility under
trusteeship March 29th and blames
management for the crisis Global News
has obtained emails between the Health
Authority and management it does show
the owners of the facility were asking
for help much of the staff was staying
home quarantined because they've been in
contact with residents with kovat 19 the
premier says that wasn't enough of a red
flag it's very nice to say I need more
workers but to say hey I'm at 31 death
in a couple of weeks that's something
very urgent now the owners of the
residents say they tried everything
including bonuses to keep staff on the
job
no but the government is telling them as
soon as you come in contact with kovin
19 that you can't come on the floor you
have to stay in in your house and
isolate for 14 days now the Herron
residence has been criticized in the
past a coroner's report into a choking
death in 2017 raised questions about the
training of staff and the owners were
sued for wrongful dismissal by a former
manager in 2018 and lost when he was
fired the manager was told he hadn't
done enough to increase occupancy and
cut costs now Ottawa has announced
guidelines to help stop the spread of
kovat 19 things like ensuring staff only
works at one facility and doesn't spread
the virus but so far only Alberta and BC
are doing that one of the reasons it can
mean a big cut to staffing already the
biggest challenge wages in the industry
are too low so many people have to work
part-time in multiple facilities the
minute you restrict where they work as
you should unless you do something more
about it then you cut your workforce by
though you know 25 percent off the top
Quebec is looking at boosting paying
some residences right now the premier
says there's a vicious circle we're an
industry that already has too few people
he's tougher and tougher and less and
less attractive as a job Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal
any facility where people are confined
in close quarters is at risk and now a
refugee shelter in downtown Toronto is
reporting an outbreak for cases of Kovac
19 have been confirmed at the Willowdale
Welcome Center test results on a number
of other residents are pending the
facility houses more than 200 refugee
claimants and physical distancing has
been difficult it is difficult to for
temporary foreign workers who come by
the thousands to work on Canadian farms
every season without them crops wouldn't
get planted harvested or processed they
are exempt from the travel restrictions
but they live in close quarters and need
to be kept safe now the federal
government is giving farmers financial
support to help to do that 15 million
dollars will go to farmers and food
processors to help cover the costs our
chief political correspondent David akin
explains David well Donna for the first
three months of last year 2019 about
23,000 temporary foreign workers were
brought to Canada to work on farms and
in food processing facilities they are a
vital source of experience labor for
Canada's agri-food industry but this
year is different
thanks to Coba 19 these foreign workers
are now subject to a strict new health
regimen in order to work in Canada it
starts in their home country with a
health assessment by an official
accredited by Health Canada each worker
will be told in their own language about
the quarantine protocol that they'll
face in Canada and they will have to
wear a mask while traveling once in
Canada every worker must be quarantined
for 14 days and during this quarantine
period employers must do the following
they must pay each worker their regular
wages during the period when they cannot
yet work they have to provide
accommodation that allows for a worker
to safely self isolate and they have to
bring food to their workers since
workers will not be allowed to visit
grocery stores or restaurants government
authorities will follow up regularly and
employers or workers who do not comply
will face severe sanctions and fines the
program announced Monday would see
employers get a subsidy of
$1,800 per worker to help cover the cost
of these quarantines but that may not
pay all the bills $1500 will certainly
be welcome for some farms it will be
enough for others it probably won't
now the government doesn't have all the
details yet about the program when can
you apply where do you apply but
Agriculture Minister marie-claude Bebo
did say that the payments will be
retroactive to March 25th
that's the date when the mandatory 14
day quarantine order went into effect
Donna okay David akin and Ottawa Thanks
here are the latest numbers on Canadians
receiving emergency financial aid nearly
six million people have applied for the
Canada emergency response benefit since
mid-march and 5.3 eight million claims
have been processed that includes people
who were previously on employment
insurance and then transferred to the
CRB program nearly one hundred and
seventy two thousand people have applied
for the benefit in the past two days
alone well we know not enough capacity
exists in Canada to test everyone for
kovat 19:00 and even if you do get
tested the results can take days to come
back now an Ottawa biotech company
Spartan bioscience has the green light
from Health Canada to scale up
production of its portable rapid kovat
19 tests that gives results within
minutes without a lab the company has
interests from all over the world but is
giving priority to Canada Abigail Beeman
explains who will get it and how it
could change the dynamic of testing in
this country the Spartan bioscience
rapid test swab cartridge and DNA
analyzer cube all made in Ottawa now
approved to ship out the first version
we just got help obtain approval and
gives results in less than an hour and
then our plan is within a few weeks to
reach a second stop version that will
give results in about 30 minutes the
automatic test doesn't need a lab it
could be used at the border in airports
and a clinic
Ottawa's priority for now is to use them
in more remote areas far from central
labs and the need is clear
we're daily getting a contacts from
surgeons about cancel all of their
elective surgeries including for cancer
patients or indigenous communities that
urgently want these tests to test their
members
Ottawa ordered more than a million test
kits rolling out 40,000 a month to start
we will get everything that this
supplier will be able to provide in the
coming months Quebec Alberta and Ontario
have placed separate orders startin
calls it's Cube extremely accurate
because it used the US Centers for
Disease Control's testing model every
test has its some limitations experts
say with a rush to get test kits to
market more publicly released data is
important we do need more scientific
data on the sensitivity specificity of
these tests so we know how to use them
properly
infection control epidemiologist Colin
Furness says rapid tests are badly
needed to figure out how to return to a
normal life one day but they're still
more figuring out to do now this is an
asymptomatic pandemic in other words the
usual rules of your you look sick
therefore we should test you that
doesn't apply in other words we haven't
actually developed an appropriate
testing strategy Canada's chief public
health officer says every Avenue is
being pursued including looking at tests
approved by other countries but dr.
Theresa Tam warns they have quote
significant concerns about the quality
of some of them and a Canadian review is
important in the race to test as fast as
possible abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa the limited amount of testing
done now does not give a true picture of
how many people in Canada have kovat 19
it's mostly the sick who are getting
tested not people with mild or no
symptoms so we have no idea what's going
on in the general population but it
appears we are flattening the curve the
stringent restrictions on our lives have
slowed the spread of the infection
Eric Sorenson is watching that curve
tonight life in Canada changed one month
ago as we began staying home and keeping
our distance the change was so dramatic
by most measurements Canada has done
well containing the Cova 19 outbreak one
important area the number of deaths
South Korea has been the standard just
four deaths per 1 million population so
far Canada is at 17 deaths per million
better even than Germany which has been
fighting the outbreak longer and much
better than the US and the U
hey though Canada is not through the
surge in deaths yet even numbers of
cases what has stood out for this
country in the first month of the crisis
is that the number of cases has risen
steadily but not exponentially on a
daily basis there was a surge in March
but then things leveled off during April
a sign that the stay at home policies
have worked provincially Quebec has been
the hardest hit there have been more
confirmed cases of kovat 19 in Quebec
than all the other provinces combined
Ontario the numbers have a bit of a
question mark because of the lack of
testing well that seems to be changing
British Columbia saw the early outbreak
but they have clearly flattened the
curves since then and Alberta may have
been the best prepared province of all
they did a lot of early testing and
remarkably had a lot of protective
equipment to share with other provinces
now among the other provinces the
numbers are smaller of course Nova
Scotia has seen the steadiest increase
that bears watching Saskatchewan is next
they did a lot of early testing
Newfoundland had a spike in early cases
though they have leveled off somewhat
the numbers remain relatively low for
Manitoba New Brunswick and Prince Edward
Island as well as the three northern
territories they've had very few cases
which is good news so far Canada has
maintained enough ICU beds though that
has coincided with a disturbing number
of residents in long-term care
facilities who were not taken to
hospital looking ahead say experts the
best way to protect the vulnerable and
all Canadians is with more testing and
say some experts maybe by summer a
revival of some parts of the economy
construction sites and other kinds of
key infrastructure places but for now
the second month with Cove in 19 may
look much like the first staying home
and being
patient Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto an unprecedented agreement
between the world's biggest oil
producers is better than nothing for
Canada's beleaguered oil and gas sector
especially in Alberta oil prices did
inch higher after OPEC and its allies
reached a deal yesterday to reduce
output by about nine point seven million
barrels a day
as Heather Eurex West explains it is not
enough though to offset the drop in
global demand for Canada's energy sector
the last few weeks have been incredibly
difficult kevin o Dwyer has had to lay
off most of his staff February 15th we
were 273 people and today we are just
over record low oil prices are behind
the turmoil a decision last month to
ramp up global production partly to
blame after several days of tense
negotiations OPEC and its russian-led
allies finally agreed Sunday to tighten
up the taps reducing output by about 10
percent it's not enough it's probably
too little too late to be honest while
the production cut is something Canada's
energy sector has been hoping for there
is little to celebrate yet that's
because the global supply for oil is
still greatly outpacing demand we're
filling up tanks quickly around the
world and there's just going to be no
place to put the oil so prices have
stayed low this morning here Monday
morning reflecting that this cut isn't
really going to change that situation we
have too much production and not enough
demand and that's a big problem it's why
Canadian oil producers have been cutting
back on production on their own the
province expects production will soon be
down 25% but in the oil sands shutting
down entirely is difficult and so the
price of a barrel of Western Canadian
SELEX will likely sink further into
negative territory where Alberta
producers would have to pay others to
take their oil away I think it's very
much a danger and we could face it in
the next two weeks the silver lining in
all of this pump prices aren't expected
to rise anytime soon but that's of
little comfort for businesses struggling
to serve
hether Eurex West Global News Calgary
deadly storms tear through America's
Deep South coming up hundreds of people
now homeless during a pandemic plus
uprooted by millions of tulips are
crushed by the corona virus
parts of the US are dealing with a
natural disaster now on top of a health
disaster tornadoes ripped through swaths
of the country at least 30 people are
dead in the deep south and hundreds more
now homeless at a time when people have
been told to stay home the same powerful
storm system moved in to the northeast
and mid-atlantic United States today a
fierce weather forced the closure of
some Kovach 19 drive-through testing
sites in Connecticut New Jersey and New
York State nowhere in the US has been
harder hit by kovin 19 than New York
State and today that state reached a
grave milestone 671 new deaths were
reported today that puts the total death
toll in New York to over 10,000 people
that's more than the next 14 states
combined there are some signs the
situation in New York is improving
though the number of new
hospitalizations is coming down to about
2,000 in the past day New York's
governor says the curve is showing signs
of plateauing and he's looking ahead to
slowly reopening businesses he says in
coordination with neighboring states if
the trend continues watch that infection
rate and if you see that infection rates
start ticking up which would be
undermining everything we have
accomplished thus far then you know
you've opened the valve too fast that is
the delicate balance an American sailor
from the USS Theodore Roosevelt aircraft
carrier has died from kovat 19 it is the
first death on board that ship which had
a corona virus outbreak sickening
hundreds of sailors the crisis exploded
into public view after the ship's
captain was relieved of his duties for
sounding the alarm about the outbreak
one of the world's largest port
processors will be shutting down a major
US facility after more than 200
employees tested positive for kovat 19
the number of cases at this Smithfield
Foods plant in South Dakota makes up 55
percent of that state's total number of
cases the company is worried the
shutdown might hurt the u.s. meat supply
at least three meat producers here in
Canada recently dealt with interruption
after workers tested positive for the
virus ahead why some European nations
are already easing restrictions at their
own risk
you are watching global national it is
tulips season but this year the flowers
are destined to be destroyed in the
Netherlands sales have been decimated by
the coronavirus so in an unprecedented
move about 400 million flowers have been
crushed over the past month it's a
bitter blow in a country where tulips
are as much a symbol of national
identity as windmills and clogs there's
a stark warning in the UK this could be
another difficult week as of today more
than 11,000 people have died of the
corona virus in the UK the rate of
infection has been steadily climbing and
has yet to flatten out neighboring
countries hit hard by the virus are
beginning to slowly ease some
restrictions but as crystal commencing
reports there are worries it may be too
soon with lockdown fatigue setting in a
stripped-down message about the pandemic
battle in the UK what do I expect to see
happen
I think this week's difficult I think
this week we're going to see a further
increase hundreds have been dying from
the virus daily the NHS has saved my
life no question the Prime Minister
Boris Johnson acknowledged his own
situation while in hospital was touching
a gold the UK is one of five countries
with a death toll of more than 10,000 as
we're going through the peak of the
crisis with the death toll the level
it's at and increasing we're absolutely
keen to make sure absolutely determined
to keep our eye on the ball and our
focus on what will save lives which is
people staying at home pressure to
restart the economy is strong and
neighbouring European countries are
beginning to ease lockdown measures in
Spain a small number of construction
workers and those in some manufacturing
sectors went back to their jobs
Italy will allow a limited number of
shops to open Tuesday the World Health
Organization says there is still a risk
now is the time for vigilance now is the
time to Double Down
now is the time to be very very careful
China is seeing new cases
after it allowed citizens to return from
other countries the WH Show will release
guidelines Tuesday for countries
considering easing lockdowns saying the
virus spreads too quickly and has proven
to be deadly not to have some
protections in place crystal the Manson
Global News London next they're having a
ball the static standards in these
baseball stands
one of the many things were deprived of
now is professional sports live events
are well they're dead
you can watch reruns of old games which
are surprisingly exciting maybe all that
tells us is how much we crave the thrill
of the game
well Taiwan has decided to bring back
baseball but the stands were empty
except for these quiet one-dimensional
fans mannequins and cardboard cutouts
took the place of live spectators the
game was broadcast live on television
though and to stay safe during the
season the players are housed in
dormitory style housing and travel only
between their housing and the stadium
may be a sign of what's to come in North
America and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna Friesen thanks for
watching and take care of yourselves bye
bye
[Music]
Oh